you should mention my brother hey
everyone my name is Randy I've got Tony
Guerrero here with me and we are talking
about ages of shield episode two of
season four just aired last night and
we're gonna talk about our top five
things to happen from the episode let's
kick it off with Daisy she still seems a
little bit crazy not really caring about
her own welfare she's you could say
she's almost suicidal she's she's
determined she wants to take down to
watch dogs but she's cut after
confronting ghostwriter she's pushed
pushing his buttons she knows who is she
did all her hacking computer
investigation she's just going further
and further and it's like if he kills
her she's okay with it but you know she
still wants vengeance against the
watchdog's she's talking about that
she's not not thinking too clearly
speaking of people aren't thinking
clearly up may is ghost at old she is
the uninfected or divisions and what was
interesting was instead of being kind of
scared and timid about the whole ghost
thing she just went out in kick some ass
she she basically defeated her entire I
guess class of like agent wash its yeah
yeah cuz it in the beginning you know at
the end of the last episode it's she was
just having little tiny bits of like she
wasn't fully infected because the guys
in the back of the truck last episode a
like tore each other apart so it was
almost like it wasn't that bad but as a
episode when she was getting worse and
worse until she's like full-on paranoia
she's like we've been infiltrated we
need to you know we need to stop this we
need do this and under like trying to
stop her and then that's where we find
out a big revelation yes this is
probably one of the biggest ones for
this episode and one of the two biggest
ones of the episode so point number
three the new director Jeffrey which is
just what he's called right now but you
have some details on this Jeffrey is a
inhuman tell me about that yeah so we
first find out like him and Coulson know
each other they don't seem like they're
the best of friends but then when when
may's losin it you know she's try
sponging nothing she takes pole nothing
and then she's like you're a monster and
he's like no I'm inhuman or something
like that so we find out he's strong he
picks her up
I just smile against the wall I'm sorry
about this well we don't know who he is
he's just referred to as Jeffrey but
what's interesting is I looked on IMDb
jason o'mara is listed as Jeffrey mace
in the comics Jeffrey mace as a
character known as patriot and he was
also the dude that took Captain
America's place he like replaced him
when he died in World War two when he
was frozen because the government's like
we can't tell a public captain Merrick
is dead so let's bring this up he
doesn't have super soldiers here or
anything like that so he took Captain
America's place it's weird that Marvel
would use that same name I don't think
it's the same character they could say
maybe he was an inhuman and maybe age
slowly i I really don't think they're
going here but it's weird that they use
that name but I did name-drop captain
america in this episode as well yeah
they need because Captain America going
missing they needed you know a new face
to yeah and and maybe that's that's the
little inside easter egg inside joke you
know captain rick is missing we get
jeffrey may so now you know it's it just
they did it with with death lock with
Michael Peterson they use a name of some
obscure character created a new one
we'll have to wait and see if they're
gonna do any of that all right let's
just let's move on to I guess the fourth
most interesting thing in this episode
is you actually got to find out a lot
more about the ghost like it's all hints
there's no real clear revelations but I
guess one of the big ones is a ghost
rider can actually hurt them so what
does this all mean well what so we find
out the one goes that they worked at
this energy lab so they go back there
time has passed as an abandoned lab and
there's other scientists that were in
these boxes so the main goes to the
woman she's spraying them and she's like
we got to get the book and they
mentioned a dark hole book which in the
comics deaths this book of sins is this
evil book this elder god chiffon made
this book and you know using it corrupts
your soul Doctor Strange used it to wipe
out vampires but because he's Doctor
Strange and sua sorcerer supreme he
wasn't he didn't succumb to the dark
nature of the book so maybe they use
this book in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and these ghosts were infected
and turned into these ghost states maybe
the you know they're going to use a dark
hole
has a kind of supernatural tied to dr.
strange obviously we're not going to
have a full-on crossover between the
movie in the show because the movies
don't reference the shows but this could
be another way you know they got ghost
writer too got these ghosts they got the
dark hold so you could have that the
other connection with chiffon if he's as
God cuz Ghost Rider mentions I sold my
soul to the devil I don't know if
they're talk much to thon you know he's
kind of a demon thing which leads us to
our fifth point basically which is right
at the end essentially ghost rider picks
up Daisy and says he thinks he's the
thing that's connecting all of this
disparate events together which I think
made you speculate okay is it dark hold
that his pal comes from is it you know
other sources what are you thinking
right now honey because you know the
fact that he he shows up where to go sir
the ghosts and he's able to burn them
and affect them so maybe there's some
connection there again whether it's
chiffon because in the comics Robbie
raised is possessed by his evil serial
killer uncle Eli moral so they haven't
mentioned Eli's name so we don't know if
the evil forces driving him to kill is
that Eli is it chiffon is it the other
spirited spirit of vengeance are at zero
those so we there so some questions we
don't know what what's going on overall
I think was a pretty good episodes I
think some of our key things that we
want to find out a bit more about is
what is the connection between ghost
rider and the ghost do you think Daisy's
gonna come back and where is Mei being
taken you told me you have a theory well
what's your major of reading the
synopsis for the next episode okay
cheating yeah basically they mentioned a
Coulson Fitz and Mac are often
submission and Simmons and and dr.
Radcliffe are racing against the clock
to try to save me before she succumbs to
this mysterious illness but it doesn't
make sense Simmons was on debate at the
base may was at the base they took her
off somewhere there's some other people
on a jet Radcliffe she's probably isn't
that far so I don't know where they
would take her why why wouldn't Jeffrey
tell Coulson what they were doing he's
like don't worry about me so okay so
what if I trust Jeffrey hopefully all
will be resolved probably not by next
week's episode and that is it
very much Tony that's our chat on ages
of shield season 4 episode 2 for more on
that and everything else in
entertainment check out gamespot
universe